personne en question
voici 19 35 mille votes
symboliques pour chaque personne sont les
il y a quelques jours, nous avons
apprendre qu'à moria la première commune
du temps a été investi maintenant quelques
jours plus tard, il a grandi de plus en plus
nous voulons que le gouvernement fédéral soit
Camps grecs et évacuer
le gouvernement fédéral s'occupant de
seins solidaires elle doit enfin
mettre les mots en action
il est temps que les gens de
peut protéger l'allemagne quand nous sommes sortis
les bâtiments du gouvernement depuis la place
Regardez
13 000 silencieux sur les 13 000 personnes
pourrait s'asseoir et c'est clair
Allemagne
[La musique]